oh [ __ ] car
could be people I don't trust this I
actually might be fine
I don't have a scope for it
okay we're clear it's always some
[ __ ] sitting in the corner there
[ __ ] your window that's what you [ __ ]
get windows it's gonna line them for
[ __ ] I'm sure I always feel like I'm
an old lady staring out the windows you
know those old people that have nothing
better to do that's how I feel like when
I play this game Oh
where's yous at bro I guess he pushed it
out told you I told you about to put
[ __ ] bro all right time to move get in
the Batmobile
[Music]
well
yeah awesome
good lad
[Music]
but Gingka is my city and I kill this
one to chat because I know he stayed
late
this is the house everyone [ __ ] goes
to
[ __ ] he definitely saw that [ __ ] see
running around
Jesus [ __ ] right whoa this guy was
dick the [ __ ] out can't even carry it
let me heal the shotgun save my life
there Jesus nice
[ __ ] you now
and trust anything now we'll take those
boots just kidding
having an epileptic well we're back to
window staring folks
[ __ ] goddamn it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] guys I'm so sorry
[ __ ] I'm out of here
later [ __ ]
I'm an excellent driver shut the [ __ ]
I know exactly what I'm doing
[Music]
actually I have no idea what I'm doing
oh-oh-oh
you didn't see me but here I am [ __ ] I
have no strategy
you may think it's [ __ ] to drive in
with the motor Bank where everyone is
most likely everyone is inside the
[ __ ] factory there is anyone in here
hi oh thank you
Dixie shucks and save my life again
Jesus Christ that's what happens when
your potatoes shot
oh Jesus what the [ __ ] was that you know
he was on a pretty good spot here don't
mind if I do
next time you you best cook your needs a
little better boy eleven people in this
circle where I'm just don't mind me I'm
just sitting by the rocks eating some
pills as you do I don't see anyone okay
oh I'm not gonna take the shot
not worth it
Oh another one they're all coming up now
this is it voice
don't mind me I'm just licking the grass
oh it's about to get really [ __ ] tiny
oh not worth it oh he's dead
nice well I'm very comfortable here guys
ooh is that a [ __ ] ghillie suit I'm
gonna have to take him out that's a free
kill sorry okay [ __ ] just got real I
sort of want to get his ghillie suits
got 20 seconds
I'm going
I'm just worried someone's behind me
that'd be the [ __ ] worst oh [ __ ] I
can just stay here hell yeah damn boy so
smooth so smooth rapid I knew exactly
what he was coming camping more like
[ __ ] you in the blue sweater I love ass
oh no some hot sexy [ __ ] boy shucks and
save my ass twice leave a like if you
want more player unknown battlegrounds
thank you my sister Fester's and as
always
sister fester